as u.s troops withdraw from afghanistan
urgent evacuations are set to begin
soon of interpreters and other afghans
who worked with american forces
60 minutes plus correspondent enrique
acevedo recently spoke to interpreters
about how
hard it is to get visas to the u.s
zaheer says he received death threats
from the taliban
he made it to america after four years
of waiting his brother-in-law and two
cousins were killed during that time
in this clip from 60 minutes plus he
talks about the dangers of the job
the thousands of afghan interpreters who
stood shoulder to shoulder with u.s
troops translating for them is only the
beginning
what kind of jobs did you end up doing
as a linguist as a translator first
thing was like to
have a secure the base
and have a patrol around the base make
sure that nothing goes wrong
and make sure there's no threat to the
base
american soldiers also relied on
interpreters for their knowledge of
regional traditions and culture
that's why they're known as the eyes and
ears of u.s armed forces
something considered treasonous by some
locals if you don't have a respect among
your own community and they think that
you are the enemy of the country
if they think that you are the traitor
of your own people
so what do you expect from the taliban
zaheer told us his life was in danger on
and off the base where he was stationed
his family lived in jalalabad a taliban
stronghold in eastern afghanistan
where he said he received several death
threats from taliban forces
you found that in your doorstep yes yes
he shared one of those letters with us
they said if you do not stop quit your
job
the islamic emirate mujahideen
will kill you and cut your head off
along with your family do you think that
wouldn't happen
yes because the taliban they were
looking for me i was in their list
to kill me and enrique joins us now
enrique good morning good to see you
so let me just clarify uh it was his
brother his father-in-law
and his two cousins um but that's just
one family
how many afghan interpreters are waiting
to come to the united states
and more importantly how long could it
take them to get here
um you're right and that's what's at
stake for these interpreters right their
lives and their families
uh well-being as well um there are 18
000
pending applications for this special
immigrant visa that's
the immigration benefit that they're
using to bring those interpreters
to the us um so imagine 18 000
applications spending and then
family members from those interpreters
staff members drivers people who were
helping
us forces and pursued shoulder to
shoulder with american soldiers in
afghanistan
now i'm glad you're shining a light on
this story because when you hear retired
general david petraeus telling you
that it would be quicker to put a rover
on mars
than to approve all these visa
applications what goes through your mind
and the mind of these interpreters
this was set up for uh betting each
applicant properly not for speed but now
with the
u.s troop withdrawal there's a sense of
urgency and it's a 14-step process that
takes on average more than three years
flat uh and it cost
thousands of dollars for these families
the medical exams
just the cost of travel to the us was
sometimes that the biggest hurdle in
order to bring these people
to the us and to take them out of
afghanistan and farm suite so enrique
it's anthony
what what are these families and what
are these interpreters doing as they as
they await approval
hi anthony well uh they're praying that
the taliban
doesn't regain full control of the
country while they're there
because they have a tight on their backs
and they know that as soon as that
happens and and that's been happening
as u.s troops withdraw from afghanistan
um as the taivan forces regain control
uh they fear they'll they'll be
assassinated and and that's what what
they're trying to avoid that's why they
want to get out of afghanistan first and
then
figure out a way to come to the us do
you get the sense on ricky that the us
is doing everything they can to get them
out because the role they played the
work they did was
crucial it would be a shame not to do
right by them at this particular time
and i think that's at the heart of our
story are we doing enough to get these
people out of afghanistan and uh i think
that
the answer is no we we
draw all the of the remaining uh us
troops from from afghanistan
without a plan to have these people um
out of danger
um and now we're sort of scrambling to
get to get them out but i don't think uh
that's happening at a pace where we're
securing these people's
well-being enrique important work that
you're doing there
uh for the crucial job that those
interpreters played for the united
states thank you very much